heute gab es ein thema das dich
besonders bewegt hat nämlich dann
interview mit dem kann ja das was er
gesagt hat der kanzleramtsminister und
die ganze debatte die wirklich neuer im
hammer ist denn bisher war das ja so
auch ich habe ihn auf meinem handy den
digitalen impfpass und da steht ganz
klar drin vollständig geimpft damit war
für mich klar für mich ist eigentlich
corona vorbei ich habe alle freiheiten
und das auch dauerhaft aber vollständig
geimpft ist jetzt nicht mehr
zwangsläufig wenn man beide peaks sich
abgeholt hat egal mit welchem impfstoff
das geld nicht mehr dieses vollständig
geimpft das hat er heute
kanzleramtsminister helge braun hierbei
bild live auch bestätigt immer mehr
deutsche werden eben einen dritten sex
brauchen das nämlich hat er gesagt er
hell wir brauchen also er macht die tür
auf dafür dass es ja selbst für die die
vollständig geimpft sind nämlich beide
pixel haben nicht mehr zwangsläufig so
ist dass sie alle freiheiten auch
genießen können so lange sie eben nicht
den dritten pickt sich auch noch
abgeholt haben das heißt die regierung
wird jetzt auch hier noch mal
nachsteuern müssen sie hat auch hier
eine gewaltige fehleinschätzung
vorgenommen und wird jetzt überrascht
davon dass die korona pandemie immer
mehr auch eben geimpfte trifft und wie
überrascht die regierung und die
spitzenpolitik davon ist zeigt diese
szene aus sachsen video konferenz von
sachsens ministerpräsident kretschmann
mit dem chef der uniklinik in leipzig
und 18 intensivpatienten sind acht die
ängste
und bei der normalstation dies sogar
größere anteil von geimpften als nicht
geimpften das heißt auch die geimpften
stellen und das ja auch an tituliert
worden eine nicht unerhebliche gefahr
dar eine frage noch mal die frau bringen
wir so es denn hängen geblieben ist sie
sagten sind auf der normalstation mehr
müsste alles umgeben
ach ja da war überrascht der sächsische
ministerpräsident kretschmann und sogar
rasch ist die gesamte bundesregierung
aktuell wie sehr diese corona pandemie
jetzt eben auch wieder bei geimpften
zulangt also dieser satz die pandemie
der ungeimpften der stimmt nicht mehr
wir haben längst auch wieder eine panne
der geimpften corona ist wieder für alle
da ja ich stimme dazu ist wird einfach
nur noch absurd was man erlebt und was
man hört und ich habe das gefühl selbst
wir die sich 24 7 mit diesen nachrichten
beschäftigen mit dem was der bike arena
passiert selbst wir kommen manchmal
nicht mehr hinterher und wissen gar
nicht so genau was gilt jetzt und ich
frage mich dann immer wenn ich dann mit
meinen eltern telefoniere die wissen gar
nicht mehr was was sie noch so holen was
sie noch dürfen was jetzt passieren
müssen sie jetzt sich noch mal impfen
müssen sie es nicht dann die frage was
ist jetzt mit zwei geben mit 3g über
alles ist unterschiedlich die die sorge
von vielen eltern dass es die schulen
wieder geschlossen werden könnten da
sind so viele offene punkte und was mich
dabei am meisten stört ist dass wir das
ganze jahr ebene seit anderthalb jahren
erleben und man sich fragt okay man
macht einen fehler man macht zwei fehler
man sagt es hat nicht so funktioniert
man entschuldigt sich aber dann wieder
alles von vorne das ist wirklich nur
noch frustriert aber sagt keiner hat bis
jetzt gesagt dass ein fehler gemacht hat
und keiner hat hier einsparen hat sehr
häufig gesagt
hat einmal im bundestag gesagt also wir
werden uns irgendwann der menge fand zu
verzeichnen haben zuletzt hatte zuletzt
hatte auch in der pressekonferenz gesagt
bei der frage wie er sich ausgedrückt
hat pandemie ende ja oder nein wenn er
da falsch wahrgenommen wurde dann tut
ihm das leid also auch da hat er sich
wieder entschuldigt naja also mit falsch
wahrnehmen und wirklich einen fehler
eingestehen ist schon riesenunterschied
und ich kann es total nachvollziehen
dass am anfang der pandemie so agiert
wurde
aber man muss dann auch irgendwann mal
umsteuern erstens gab es leute die genau
davor gewarnt haben ja schon auch am
anfang der impfung gesagt hat das könnte
passieren warum setzt man sich nicht mit
diesen leuten in ruhe hin und überlegt
wie können wir das jetzt am besten an
packendes punkt 1.2 ist wir leben in
einer freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung und wir haben nach wie vor
eine einschränkung von grundrechten
die das muss man erklären und das hieß
mal wenn jedem ein angebot zur verfügung
steht dann müssen wir aber auch wieder
zum thema eigenverantwortung
zurückkommen seit anderthalb jahren wird
auch mit angst gearbeitet massivst mit
angst gearbeitet das ist haben sie ihren
parteikollegen helge braun mal gefragt
warum wir das immer macht ja weil er die
zahlen sieht und sagt das wird alles
ganz schlug der malte ja auch selbst
oder das ist angst getrieben ja wir
haben hier ein thema ohne wenn und aber
wir wissen aber auch spätestens jetzt
dass das so nicht in den griff bekommen
und die menschen sind mittlerweile leid
und das ist das eigentliche thema wenn
man sagt ja immer es gibt ein
medizinisches ende der pandemie und
soziales ende der pandemie
die leute sind nicht nur zutiefst
verunsichert sie machen auch in vielen
bereichen nicht mehr mit was
höchstwahrscheinlich jetzt gerade das
problem ist und da frage ich mich warum
ist man nicht bereit mit
unterschiedlichen meinungen sich an dem
tisch zu setzen zu sagen okay so hat es
jetzt nicht funktioniert die machen es
andere länder also ich war jetzt vor ein
paar tagen in dänemark
die haben gesagt bei uns wir wissen alle
wie wir damit umgehen aber bei uns
gibt's keine maßnahmen mehr und die
gehen vernünftig damit um und bei uns
passiert genau das gegenteil und ich
befürchte dass wenn wir so weiter machen
und ich fand das auch ziemlich schlimm
das thema zweig und die panamedia
ungeimpften weiterhin diese spaltung der
gesellschaft zu betreiben sich jetzt mal
hinzusetzen sagen okay der weg scheint
nicht ganz der richtige gewesen zu sein
wir holen alle experten an den tisch und
überlegen wie wir das vernünftig durch
den winter kommen müller vogg sie
beobachten die politik seit vielen fehlt
die hc man sagen insbesondere die cdu
warum ist das entschuldigen so schwer
also sechsmal wenn sich die politik für
inflation entschuldigen hat in der sache
ist sind die administrativen dingen also
beispielsweise das im letzten leider
dass der sommer verpasst wurde die
schulen entsprechend aufzurüsten
umzurüsten lüftern und alles was wir da
machen konnte da ist da ist vieles
passiert auch vieles versäumt worden
auch administrativ weil bei der
organisation der impfung das war auch
manchen ländern katastrophalen anderen
hat es geklappt also das war alles das
ist also das suboptimale
um das so zu formulieren aber ein dass
man sich außerhalb ich hätte in den
letzten anderthalb jahren den letzten 20
monaten nicht politiker sein wollten
weil sie müssen entscheidungen treffen
sozusagen vor dem hintergrund dass sie
wirklich gar nicht wissen was da abläuft
das hat die mediziner sagen ja wir haben
ein impfstoff der wirkt so inzwischen
sagen dieselben experten
ja aber da muss man wieder aufrichten
aber für solche herausforderung
begriffen doch dann habe ich den job
falsch verstanden das ist natürlich sehr
spezielle und sehr sehr harte krise aber
man geht doch genau für solche riesen
für solche schwierigen entscheidungen in
die politik dafür müssen die leute doch
gemacht sei die regierung eigentlich
kenne kein politiker ich weiß nicht wie
bei ihnen war die gesagt haben also ich
möchte sie die politik weil ich erwarte
dass ist der himmel einstürzt nein also
hab ich auch nicht gesagt aber auch
herausforderungen dar aber das ist eine
herausforderung wenn wir eine tiefe
wirtschaftskrise haben dann hat man
erfahrungswerte dann sagen die einen da
muss jetzt starten ja machen und die
anderen sagen wir müssen
den markt stützen oder wir müssen mehr
sozialpolitik waren manche haben aber
keiner fahren können
da könnte da können sie auch erfahren so
kann bei dieser pandemie sind wir doch
alle mit der stange im nebel also
behauptet er hätte das schon im februar
dieses jahres gewusst wie das alles aber
es gibt ja ein unterschied finde ich
zumindest dass man am anfang irgendwie
bei null stand und gesagt hat jetzt eine
pandemie was war ja dass man dafür macht
absoluter chor aber dass dann nach
anderthalb jahren bei bestimmten dingen
wie zum beispiel der frage was mit den
schulen passiert was mit den altenheimen
passiert da wo wieder keine
schutzmaßnahmen vorgenommen wurden und
viele viele weitere beispiele
da muss man doch sagen das ist dann am
ende polit versagt ja gut da bin ich
allein ich sage ihm an die tarifbereiche
ziel 20 glauben lässt sich dann schuldig
sind dann würde sich die bundesregierung
entschuldigen da müssen sich die
landesregierung entschuldigen da müssen
sich die kommunen entschuldigen damit
hat sich die granden habe es gar nicht
entschuldigen aber da ist sozusagen den
bereich ist viele fans gehabt mein punkt
waren ja bei der ebene also wenn sich
schon vor einem jahr gewusst haben dass
die zweite impfung nicht ausreicht dann
war frage ist nicht wo blieb die große
schlagzeile in der bild leute richtet
euch auf yamaha zum ein reines gewissen
denn wir müssen nicht oder wenig ein
ganzes jahr zurück aber wir wussten es
spätestens im sommer nämlich hier ab dem
zeitpunkt ab dem israel die dritte im
verbrecher geführt hat das ist jetzt
genau die studie die helge braun in
jedem interview und auch viren sparen in
jedem interview zitieren nach israel
gucken wenn man frühzeitig nach israel
geguckt hätte dann wäre man jetzt
nämlich vorbereitet dann stünden nämlich
überall die zelte mit den impfzentren
dann würde man schon längst nämlich
bostan dreißigste juli das war der
stichtag in israel ab da wurde
geburtstag in deutschland fängt man das
jetzt langsam an wie bastelt man in der
schweiz ja gut dass das grundproblem in
dieser ganzen chor ohne geschichte ist
einfach dass sich der start total
übernommen hat ich meine das ist ja
völlig verrückt dass der staat die
verantwortung quasi für die gesundheit
des gesamten volkes auf sich nehme das
ist ja eine kollektive entmündigung die
in der stadt gefunden und der stadt
gesagt hier ist ja gar nicht was sie
anders machen mit der miete gesund
bleibt wir sagen euch jetzt was sie zu
tun hat und es stimmt nicht ganz das
wäre daneben toppen wir wissen ziemlich
genau für welche personengruppen dieses
virus besonders gefährlich ist es gibt
einfach risikogruppen aber mein gefühl
ist einfach dass die politiker sind
gefangene ihrer eigenen politischen
korrektheit ihrer rhetorik der
solidarität wir müssen alle sind
gleichermaßen betroffen davon das stimmt
nicht man man hat verlernt
unterscheidungen zu machen präzis zu
sein wenn du ein problem lösen willst
musst du doch das problem aller ist und
das problem ist dass ganz spezifische
gruppen von menschen besonders bedroht
sind oder musste doch deine maßnahmen
auf das ausrichten aber die haben ja die
ganze welt in die geiselhaft genommen
ich meine ist doch völlig verrückt was
an den schulen läuft auch in der schweiz
was sie da gemacht haben
schulschließungen masken pflicht für
kinder all dieses zeug dann die frage
des impfens keine sind wir eigentlich
von allen guten geistern verlassen dass
politiker die keine ahnung haben von
irgendwas uns jetzt plötzlich noch sagen
welche medizinischen behandlungen wie
man auch die regierung reagieren und in
die körpersäfte hinein und da sage ich
einfach tschuldigung eine impfung was da
alles erzählt und ich bin auch geimpft
ich bin ich gegen impfungen aber ich
sage
jetzt genau den chefposten das haben sie
uns gesagt das sei der absolute schutz
jetzt sind die geschützte gar nicht
geschützt und die müssten von den tisch
geschützte mussten vor den ungeschützten
geschützt werden weil der schutz gar
nicht schuld dass etwas nicht